The change goes in the octopus for a few reasons.
First off, we don't want to mess up the data that we already have.
And second of all, we don't actually need to change the data itself.
It's just the way we're getting the data from the model to the view.
Now, why not the view; why not put this in the view?
Well first of all, the view shouldn't pull things directly from the model.
Remember, they shouldn't talk directly.
So as long as we're going through the octopus,
it makes sense to give the view only what it needs.
Now that being said, technically you could put this functionality in the view.
But for my model view octopus example, I'm going to leave it in the octopus.
The octopus is where I want all of the real smarts to
live in this organizational paradigm.
Whereas the model and the view themselves, are relatively simple.
Now if you use other organizational libraries, they all have
different opinions about where exactly different functionalities should live.
But in all of those cases, they're consistent and well thought out.
So for MVO, we're going to keep all of the smart functionality and
the filtering and everything, in the octopus